I always like to give an example of
Myspace because I just think it's an
amusing story so my space was poised I
would say to be Facebook right it was
huge it was viral it was lots of things
kind of foreshadowed a bit of maybe even
Tick Tock because it was like a lot of
entertainment content casual
um and then Rupert Murdoch bought it and
it collapsed within a few years and part
of that I think was because they were
really really
heavy on ads and less heavy on the
customer experience so I remember to
accept a friend request was like three
clicks where you saw three ads and on
Facebook you accept the friend request
you didn't even leave the page it just
like that just accepted
but what is interesting so I used to
give this example of like yeah well
Rupert Murdoch really screwed out that
one up and in a sense maybe did but
somebody said you know what actually he
bought it for and I don't remember the
numbers he bought it for 800 million and
it was very profitable
through its decline
they actually made his money back and
more so it wasn't like from a financial
point of view it was a bad investment in
the sense of you could have been
Facebook but on sort of more mundane
metrics it's like actually worked out
okay for it all matters how you define
success it does and that that is also
advice to young people
um one of the things I I would say like
when we have our mental models of
success as an entrepreneur for example
and your examples in your mind are Bill
Gates Mark Zuckerberg so people who at a
very young age
um had one really great idea that just
went straight to the moon and became one
of the richest people in the world that
is really unusual like really really
rare and for most entrepreneurs that is
not the life path you're going to take
you're going to fail you're going to
reboot you're going to learn from what
you failed at you're going to try
something different and that is really
important because if you're a standard
of success is
well I feel sad because I'm not as rich
as Elon Musk it's like well so should
almost everyone possibly everyone except
Elon Musk is not as rich as Elon Musk
and so that you know like realistically
you can set a standard of success even
even in a really narrow sense which I
don't recommend of thinking about your
financial success
it's like if you measure your financial
success by thinking about billionaires
like that's that's heavy like that's
probably not good I don't recommend it
um whereas like I personally I you know
like for me when people when journalists
say oh how does it feel to not be a
billionaire I usually say I don't know
how does it feel to you
because they're not
um but also I'm I'm like I live in
London
the number of Bankers that no one's ever
heard of who live in London who make far
more money than I ever will is quite a
large number and I wouldn't trade my
life for theirs at all right because I
mine is so interesting like oh right
um Jimmy we need you to go and meet the
Chinese propaganda Minister yeah okay
that's super interesting like yeah Jimmy
you know like here's the situation like
you can go to this country and and while
you're there
um the president has asked to see you I
was like God that's super interesting
Jimmy you're going to this place and
there's a local wikipedian who said do
you want to stay with me and my family
and I'm like yeah like that's really
cool like I would like to do that that's
really interesting
um don't do that all the time but I've
done it and it's great so like for me
that's like arranging your life so that
you have interesting experiences is just
great